[Musique]
avec vous Hélène Frade bonjour Hélène
bonjour Pauline avant cela Hélène dans
la presse la rencontre aujourd'hui à
Bali en Indonésie on en parlait à
l'instant en marche du G20 entre les
présidents chinois et américains Sylvie
et Joe Biden c'est leur premier tata
tête depuis l'élection de l'Amérique et
comme pour relativiser voir minimiser ce
rendez-vous le quotidien officiel
chinois de Global Times qui affirme que
cette rencontre est une proposition
américaine évoque surtout ce matin les
attentes réelles ou supposées de la
communauté internationale vis-à-vis de
la Chine sur laquelle beaucoup de
nations fonderaient de grands espoirs je
cite l'espoir que PK affirme son
leadership que la Chine joue un plus
grand rôle dans la résolution des défis
mondiaux et conduisent je cite toujours
le monde vers un avenir plus pacifique
et plus prospère la presse
occidentale avec le Financial Times
présente quand elle cette rencontre
comme un test pour un Joe Biden dopé par
les élections mi-mandat le test en
question consistant à vérifier si le
président américain sera en mesure
d'inverser le déclin spectaculaire des
relations sino-américaines le quotidien
britannique site les très nombreux
différents qui opposent Washington EPK
le commerce les armes nucléaires la
Russie est bien sûr Taïwan sur ce
dossier le Wall Street Journal qui
oppose lui un président américain
vieillissant à un fishing confiant et de
plus en plus agressif accuse Joe Biden
de n'avoir aucune stratégie économique
viable vis-à-vis de l'île et il en veut
pour preuve l'accord commercial
concluant mai dernier entre les
Etats-Unis et Taiwan l'IPEV un accord
présenté comme une version édulcorée du
fameux partenariat transpacifique le TPP
qui avait été mise en place par Barack
Obama avant d'être abandonné par Donald
Trump
et on y reviendra sur les enjeux de
cette visite dans le décryptage avec
Bilal tarabé dans la presse également ce
matin en lisait tout à l'heure elle aime
cette enquête édifiante difficile à lire
du monde ce matin sur le naufrage en
novembre 2021 il y a presque un an d'une
embarcation transportante des candidats
à l'exil au large de Calais au cours
duquel 27 personnes ont trouvé la mort
c'est le pire drame enregistré dans la
Manche alors que vous l'avez dit la
France et le Royaume-Uni pourraient
assigner ce matin un accord pour
intensifier la lutte contre les
traversées clandestines le monde dit
avoir eu accès à une partie des
investigations en cours sur son naufrage
aux communications qui ont été
enregistrées entre 7 embarcation
naufragés et le cross le Centre Régional
opérationnel de surveillance et de
sauvetage maritime du Pas-de-Calais ces
communications révèlent que les
occupants du bateau ont appelé à de très
nombreuses reprises les secours français
en l'espace de trois heures seulement et
que ces derniers les ont
systématiquement renvoyés au secours
britannique au motif que leur
embarcation ce serait trouvé alors dans
les autres territoriales anglaises pour
le moment le compte-rendu des échanges
côté britanniques n'a pas encore été
joint à l'enquête mais les
communications du côté français sont
effectivement totalement accablante
comme cet aparté d'une opératrice du
cross réagissant à la pelle au secours
d'un de ces migrants littéralement en
train de se noyer cette opératrice tente
de transférer l'appel vers Douvres la
communication coupe et on l'entend alors
commenter à battant pas tu seras pas
sauvé j'ai les pieds dans l'eau bah je
t'ai pas demandé de partir
à lire dans le monde quelques mois à
présent Hélène de la coupe du monde de
foot au Qatar coup d'envoi en fin de
semaine elle continue à provoquer
beaucoup de romans et le quotidien
L'Humanité quotidien communiste français
propose ce matin Pauline cette enquête
réalisée au Népal auprès de travailler
sur les chantiers du Mondial ces
ouvriers racontent avoir vécu l'enfer
après s'être lourdement endetté auprès
d'agence de recrutement pour pouvoir
aller travailler au Qatar ces agences
exigent ont exigé des sommes colossales
distillent notamment via des prêts au
taux d'intérêt exorbitants de 48 à 60%
interrogé par l'humain le président de
la Fédération des palaise des syndics le
président de la Fédération des syndicats
népalais oui dénonce lui les conditions
économiques qui forcent ces jeunes
compatriotes à partir donc notamment au
Qatar où les syndicats sont interdits on
n'exporte plus des tapis mais des
humains des non style
ce témoignage et tous les autres
continuent en effet à provoquer beaucoup
d'indignations à travers le monde
notamment en Israël ou arrête s'accuse
les fans de la Coupe du Monde de la FIFA
de célébrer je cite les corps brisés et
les espoirs anéantides de centaines de
milliers de travailleurs étrangers
maltraitaient et sous-payés au Qatar
indignation également au Royaume-Uni
avec cette fois cette tribune du gardien
qui considère que cette coupe du monde
va sans doute mettre en évidence
l'argent et le pouvoir de cet état du
Golfe mais qu'elle lève aussi un peu
plus le voile sur ses violations en
matière des droits de l'homme le gardien
ne se dessin de Ben Jenning se montre le
trophée de la Coupe du Monde
trônant face à des tribunes ou les
fauteuils ont été remplacés par des
pierres tombales avec ce slogan dites
non aux droits de l'homme
on ne se quitte pas là dessus Hélène si
cette riante d'actualité Pauline vous ne
éventuellement envie de changer de
carrière sachez que la France se manque
cruellement de mathématiciens alors que
l'enseignement de mathématiques va de
nouveau être obligatoire en classe de
première je suis pas sûr que ça suffit
susciter des dévocations de temps que
depuis les années 2000 le nombre
d'enseignants chercheurs en
mathématiques chute d'après la croix qui
rappelle que chaque campagne de
recrutement se termine avec des places
non pourvues à vie aux candidat moi
clairement sert à tes je crois MERCI
BEAUCOUP Hélène à tout à l'heure dans
Paris direct